um i'd like to close with just one  observation which has struck me forcibly  in the last few months when i've been  watching all of vanessa's work  in a cinema now largely taken up with  robots elves  androids cartoons hobgoblins vampires  cgi caricatures  murderers with machine guns bearded folk  in hessian  gods in sandals  spiritual guides gurus and assorted  visitors from a third dimension  the woman whom tennessee williams called  the greatest actress of her time  resolutely goes on playing human beings  at the full depth of their humanity  and now everyone i'd like to lead your  applause to celebrate vanessa's life in  the cinema more power to that  you